the pedestrian zone in the historic town
of bad monster eiffel is crowded during
the Christmas shopping season the town
was once a health spa now the attraction
is a factory outlet center investors
bought a group of half-timbered houses
and spent millions of euros renovating
them in August some 30 factory outlet
businesses set up shop since opening the
outlet center has had some 300,000
visitors the manager is extremely
satisfied with the success of the new
sales concept galavan's eat I think if
you visit the local retailers they'll be
smiling from ear to ear since we opened
they've been handed more customers on a
silver platter than they know what to do
with in just a few months they've done
more business than they used to do in
the entire year chef de marques is on
some constant nagging left arden the
outlet center mainly sells sports wear
shoes and apparel reduced by up to
seventy percent there's hardly any
expensive designer gear the center is
about an hour by car from cologne many
days it's overrun up to two million
visitors are expected next year the vast
majority of them are pensioners you've
been other than I really like the outlet
center because I can find fashionable
stuff here otherwise I'd have to drive
to Dusseldorf often or cologne so it's
great Finn's guns gorge you have to hose
the main thing is I have a good fashion
advisor with me who helps me find what I
need the rest is not that interesting
into some defense Nick I think it's nice
it's not flashy it's very laid back I
think that's good Finn's couch before
the centre opened about fifteen percent
of the shops here were empty residents
had moved away because there was no work
for the mayor the outlet center was a
stroke of luck it's brought new jobs
revenues are rising it's revitalized our
downtown it's one of a kind in the
entire country I wish the trend would
turn to putting businesses back in city
centres rather than in five
yields its exemplary urban planning and
in my opinion these kind of concepts
create more opportunities than building
something tacky out in the suburbs the
outlet center currently takes up about a
third of the historic town center it's
planning to double its size to attract
even more customers